eu era uma pessoa que acreditava que o
brasil vivia uma democracia racial
era uma pessoa que olhava pra esse
auditório e não me espantava o fato de
ver muitos poucos negros presentes
eu achava que era normal
é assim que é o brasil e talvez os
negros não estejam nesse auditório como
de fato também não estão hoje porque não
querem vir talvez não seja do interesse
deles discutir alguma coisa ligada até
dex eu achava natural ver brancos
ocupando espaços em todas as dimensões
do nosso país eu era absolutamente
alheio à dor daqueles que não estão
presentes nesse auditório hoje eu achava
que não existia do que era algo natural
e como todos os brancos do nosso país eu
naturaliza vá ausência de todos os
negros e negras de todos os espaços
possíveis e imaginários
eu entrava no cinema e não achava
estranho não existirem negros
participando daquele momento cultural
eu ia ao teatro e não via negros eu ia
ao shopping não via negros e eu me
perguntava por que eu simplesmente não
entendia existia o motor por trás disso
que havia uma dor que deveria ser
pesquisada entendida vivenciada
percebida e eu acreditava nesse mito da
democracia racial somos um país aonde
nós democraticamente
temos espaço para todos e percebi que
não era verdade
eu percebi isso do início dos anos 2000
quando tive oportunidade de começar a me
envolver a partir de um convite de uma
pessoa que eu não conhecia negra que
veio a mim e disse vocês brancos têm um
papel a cumprir na promoção da igualdade
racial desse país e porque agora em 2001
vai haver uma conferência mundial contra
o racismo e nessa conferência mundial
contra o racismo ações devem ser tomadas
para que o brasil se transforme mas o
convite não foi feito a partir de uma
fala tão simples quanto essa foi o
convite cheio de emoção foi o convite
cheio de dor e foi o convite pela
primeira vez que eu recebi na minha vida
com o dedo em riste apontado pra mim
aonde este querido amigo que já faleceu
e se tornou um grande amigo um grande
aliado um grande apoiador de brancos
defendendo a causa negra ele disse mas
você preste atenção numa coisa quem é o
protagonista desse processo somos nós
negros após que vai falar nesse processo
é a voz de nós negros e negras
eu não entendia porque isso eu não
entendia qual seria o papel de um homem
branco num processo de promoção de
igualdade racial
aonde eu tivesse os negros e negras como
os protagonistas e promotores e eu
percebi uma coisa
à medida que eu ia e apropriando dessa
dor e percebendo essa dor eu não poderia
me apropriar do processo porque se eu me
apropriar se do processo no sentido de
eu me tornar o protagonista eu faria de
novo a repetição de uma história
conhecida de todos
nós que é ver esse auditório a maioria
branca quer ver os espaços de decisão
desse país com maioria branca e que
agora se tornam vocaliza dores da dor do
outro e o que isso faz faz simplesmente
a eternização do problema se tornar uma
realidade
daí então percebermos que nós podemos
ser apoiador e sim da causa feminista
mas sem nos apropriarmos dessa causa nós
homens mas sim nos tornarmos apoiadores
dessa causa onde a vocalização se dá
através das mulheres sim aonde a
apropriação do processo das mulheres sim
é só essa forma que eu tenho de me
tornar um bom apoiador da causa
feminista para que o empoderamento e pra
que a liderança do processo têm as
mulheres à sua frente para que a
sociedade se transforma
o mesmo se aplica à questão da promoção
da igualdade racial
eu não posso me tornar uma grande
referência branca que analisa a questão
negra e que diz a sociedade como é que
nós temos que agir não é isso que
acontece hoje quando nós falamos sobre a
causa indígena
quem são aqueles antropólogos que
analisam a sociedade indígena
quem são aqueles homens e mulheres de
excelente intenção de maravilhosa
determinação que aparecem em todos os
espaços públicos
falando sobre os indígenas e dizendo
esse é o problema esse é o desafio é
isso que eles precisam é assim que vamos
trabalhar
nós analisamos e conhecemos e
antecipamos a sociedade indígena e
trazemos para vocês
o que é necessário ser feito
quem foram os grandes nomes que
analisaram a realidade negra brasileira
se apropriaram do processo se tornar os
porta vozes e se tornar os localizadores
de uma causa que não entender o que é
lamentável quando isso acontece porque
nós somos por exemplo os herdeiros de um
pensamento freiriano em foi gilberto
freyre
o que foi que ele analisou da realidade
negra ao chegar e dizer que havia uma
cordialidade entre a casa grande ea
senzala
ele vivenciou a senzala
ele sabia o que era dor que você tem que
encontrar uma estratégia de
sobrevivência
pra que então você pudesse levar adiante
uma vida minimamente possível e daí eu
concluir a partir da visão daquele que
se apropria do processo e quer então
fazer valer o entendimento a partir do
seu olhar é possível eu como homem
branco consegui perceber o olhar de uma
pessoa negra e como ela percebe o mundo
e como ela é percebida pelo mundo
impossível
por mais que eu me dedique durante
décadas a causa negra causa feminista
causa indígena
eu não vou conseguir vivenciar com os
olhos dela
eu tenho uma filha a psicóloga hoje mas
que aos três anos de idade me ensinou
psicologia e eu saquei que ela ia ser
psicóloga não tinha mais dúvidas sobre
isso
o dado instante rodar um pito nela três
anos de idade tinha figura
ela olha pra mim e disse você não tá
dentro de mim pra saber o que eu tô
sentindo
sim senhora
aprendi a lição eu não tô dentro de um
negro de uma negra para saber o que ela
está sentindo que ele está sentindo e eu
não consigo perceber o que significam
dados estatísticos por exemplo se eu não
vivencia aquilo que o olhar de um negro
de uma negra capaz de perceber a
realidade brasileira e como é que eu
reajo eu reagir dizendo não mas não tem
racismo que isso você está exagerando
aquela situação que você passou não era
por racismo
e se até uma pessoa branca passaria por
isso esse olhar que nós precisamos mudar
e nós somente mudaremos este olhar
somente perceberemos que nós cada um de
vocês aqui presentes
brancos ou se quiserem se autodenominar
não negros como queiram
porque dizer quem é branco na sociedade
brasileira um grande desafio mas quem é
que sabe exatamente dizer quem é branco
que é negro aqui no brasil e sabe
classificar direitinho isso não tem
nenhuma dificuldade de fazer essa
classificação quem sabe de quem é
polícia e porteiro de prédio ele
direitinho sabe quem vai ter que ir pela
entrada dos fundos o porteiro do prédio
eo policial sabe direitinho quem ele tem
que parar e revistar e nós dizemos nós
somos uma sociedade aonde essa mescla
maravilhosa se face somos uma sociedade
mestiça onde não há o preconceito a
questão é social
ela não é racial não é verdade não é
verdade a questão racial sim senhor
nós somos uma sociedade racista sim
senhor porque nós sabemos exatamente
como funciona o sistema
as mulheres negras sabe exatamente como
funciona o sistema público de saúde
deste país aonde estatísticas da do data
sus
no estudo feito pela doutora jurema
werneck médica negra carioca indica que
14 por cento de mulheres brancas recebe
anestésico dentro de um procedimento do
parto quando o médico decide que a
anestesia deve ser aplicada e somente 7%
das mulheres negras recebem anestésico
qual é a lógica dessa decisão
se não uma lógica discriminatória e
racista não quer qual seria a diferença
da mulher branca pra mulher negra
fisiologicamente biologicamente nenhuma
mas qual é a lógica daquele obstetra
daquela obstetra
ele olha mulher negra e diz forte
descendente de escravos
olha mulher branca e diz tão fraquinho
tão delicada merece anestésico
a outra não merece como eu ronco isso
como eu rompi sistema cruel que se
estabeleceu em nosso país e que merece
ser desafiado só uma única forma que é a
crença de que nós verdadeiramente
compomos uma única espécie humana
se nós tivermos a certeza que nós
compomos uma única espécie humana daí eu
consigo romper isso na medida que eu
percebo que o compõem uma única espécie
humana
eu aceito o dedo em riste do meu amigo
sérgio martins e eu digo certo você tem
toda a razão desse dedo em riste e eu me
coloco no
a posição de humildade numa posição de
transparência numa posição de
acolhimento e aceitação para entender a
sua dor você que é parte do meu corpo
porque eu entendo a humanidade como
único somente quando eu percebi a
unidade essencial da humanidade
somente quando eu percebo que nós
constituímos uma única espécie
eu entendo como eu posso me tornar o
guardião da espécie todo o desafio que
eu trago pra vocês refletirem hoje nesse
momento é como seria a humanidade
se nós estabelecemos um princípio que eu
chamaria the guardian nia coletiva da
humanidade
cada um é responsável pelo todo eo todo
é responsável pela segurança de cada um
não é assim que funciona o nosso corpo
humano
já notaram isso se eu tenho uma unha
encravada no dedão do pé lá atrás o
cérebro tão superior aqui em cima eles
pessoal atenção utilizemos nos todos
porque a saúde do corpo ea saúde minha
como cérebro é tão importante quanto a
saúde daquela área pequena em torno do
dedão do pé porque não há aqui escala
hierárquica
aqui há uma percepção de um corpo que
funciona em sintonia e uníssono em
verdadeira harmonia
daí então as células do fígado as
células de várias partes do corpo elas
começam a se mobilizar para fazer com
que o corpo proteja o corpo inteiro e
proteger aquelas pequenas células em
volta do de dom da unha encravada do seu
pé
porque se não conseguirem fazer isso
o corpo inteiro pode sucumbir com uma
infecção generalizada
então é esse o nosso desafio estamos
dispostos a ver nos uns aos outros como
partes essenciais de um mesmo corpo
estamos dispostos nós a vemos uns aos
outros
brancos ou negros ou indígenas
brasileiros japoneses até argentinos
como iguais
se nós estamos dispostos a isso nós
conseguiremos fazer com que o corpo se
mantenha sadio
hoje o corpo da humanidade se encontra
em profunda doença porque não há como
encontrar solução para esse dilema e
médicos inaptos incompetentes querem
cuidar do corpo da humanidade com várias
soluções milagrosas e soluções essas que
não consegue atacar o dilema e o
problema essencial problema essencial é
dos vermos como partes de uma unidade
única de uma humanidade essencialmente
igual
é nisso que me traz de novo o desafio
que se apresentou ao fazer essa fala se
é possível um branco ser defensor da
causa negra e eu diria até mais adiante
é possível um homem branco ser defensor
da causa da mulher negra a mulher negra
que em nosso país
ela se encontra na pior situação de
discriminação de toda a escala social
brasileira homem branco mulher branca
homem negro ou mulher negra pode o homem
branco ser o defensor da causa da mulher
negra
sim desde que ele perceba e ele não se
torna o que se apropria da causa não é
ele o porta voz da causa
ele é simplesmente um co
colaborador laboram em conjunto é
possível branco se tornarem defensores
da causa negra sim é possível
deixe-nos percebamos como elemento de
uma única humanidade
esse é o maior desafio de nosso país
se eu puder dizer qual é o grande
desafio brasileiro hoje não está na
economia o grande desafio hoje não tá
nas estruturas políticas
o grande desafio do brasil hoje está
nessa distância e incomensurável entre
uma elite branca de uma maioria de uma
população negra quase 60% de uma
população brasileira que se encontra
herdeira de um processo que tem que ser
cumprido e é isso meu convite a vocês
pensem em como podemos nos tornar
grandes defensores de grandes causas que
sim dizem respeito a cada um de nós
muito obrigado